what's going on guys this is rob and
gather round children gather round let
papa rob teach you about blade
here's the funny thing right i'm doing
this because hopefully they're going to
drop some information about blade at san
diego which is going to drive up
interest and people will watch this
video if that doesn't happen this video
is probably gonna flop i don't know
we'll find out but if you really want me
to blow your mind and we're gonna talk
about this later blade did not become a
day walker in marvel comics until after
the blade movie was released in 1999 i
know crazy right so check this out
so blade originally appeared in mobile
comics back in tomb of dracula issue
number 10 in 1973 and he was created by
marv wolfman and gene cullen now an
important thing to understand here is
that blade was very similar to luke cage
in so far that he was marvel's attempt
to capitalize on the existing
blaxploitation movement taking place in
hollywood which is to say the desire of
marvel comics to bring in black
audiences by basically creating
characters that were black themselves
and usually playing some kind of a
heroic role the funny thing about this
is that there was an interview that was
done by gene coleman back in 2003 and
tomorrow's publishing where he was
talking about the creation of blade and
saying and really seeming to illustrate
this idea that marv wolfman of course
said blade needs to be a black guy and
the creation of him as we saw him at
that point in time really seemed to be a
tried-and-true collaboration between
both gene colon and marv wolfman which
in reality was something that happened
very rarely in the 60s and 70s in marvel
comics more often what you would find is
you would find like a person would
create something and then they would say
they're the ones that created everything
as opposed to it actually being the
writer and artist both who essentially
worked on it but the thing about this
and what's really going to strike you as
being fascinating here is the way blade
was depicted in the early tomb of
dracula stories and really running all
the way up until he reappeared in 1984.
it doesn't really look anything like the
blade that you know and in fact he was
depicted the way you saw fashion and
characters depicted back during that
point in time the only real thing we had
about him is that he just kind of
appeared in troom of dracula issue
number 10 faced off against dracula and
then appeared over the course of that
comic so between 1973 and 1974 he
appeared in issues 10 12 13 14 17
through 19 21 24 and 30. so he was just
kind of like an off-again on-again
villain of dracula that would just show
up at differing points in time now the
reality here was that over the course of
the of 1973 going into 1974 blade was
actually gaining popularity he was
gaining a lot of interest among comic
book readers because he was just so
different you know the truth about tomb
of dracula is that in a lot of ways it
wasn't so much a holdover of marvel
publishing when they were atlas comics
publishing science fiction stories but
it was the desire of marvel as they were
publishing at the time to see if it was
marketable to bring back the horror
element at least in some kind of a comic
and see if it would stick and it did the
tomb of dracula comic is considered one
of them one of the best comic runs that
marvel had in relation to the character
of dracula and in fact because of that
comic dracula has stayed popular in
marvel comics for decades right that run
right there is kind of seminal now you
may not have heard of it if you're not
familiar with dracula but for those
individuals out there who love the
character of dracula it's a landmark
story and in fact one of the most
significant stories of marv wolfman and
gene cullen now the thing about this is
that by the time he got to the 30th
issue that's when marvel was looking at
the idea of doing something a little bit
different with his character and so in
issue number 30 what they did is they
basically wrote him out of the dracula
stories by basically having a scenario
where blade approached dracula and then
pitched this idea to him that what he
wanted to do was essentially serve as
dracula's agent operating out there and
really like fast track vampires
conquering the world then what he had
done was put out this idea that vampires
were going to conquer the world but what
people like blade could do is they could
actually make that happen faster of
course dracula very much enjoying that
idea ended up accompanying blade only to
be ambushed by blade and a handful of
his allies now this was kind of the
extension of the nature of black
exploitation and the building of blades
entourage as it existed in the time in
the sense that it was largely a black
group so again marvel really trying to
tie into uh bringing in black fans at
that point in time so of course they
ended up not really killing dracula but
kind of overpowering him he was somewhat
left for dead and then in turn one of
his agents had shown up they had killed
a few members of blade's group and then
in turn went forward from there right
dracula basically escaped and then blade
kind of struck out on his own and that's
where the vampire tales comics came into
play now vampire's tales it was
interesting for what it was but it was
basically just a black and white comic
at the time now something that i do want
to point out about this initiative is
vampire tales was an incredibly
important comic for a couple different
reasons and it wasn't really even a
comic it was a magazine so the idea one
of the things we've talked about was the
comics code authority basically the
governing body of comic books the comics
had to follow rules at the time if they
wanted to receive the seal of approval
from the comics code which for parents
buying comics for their kids was
paramount so think of it as the comic
book equivalent of like movie the movie
rating system now or tv rating systems
video game rating systems that kind of a
thing and so what this meant was that by
publishing vampire tales as a magazine
under magazine management incorporated
which was actually the owner of marvel
comics but not publishing the magazine
directly as a marvel comic itself it
allowed them to circumvent the entirety
of the comics code which basically meant
they could have like some mild profanity
i mean there wasn't really anything
outright in terms of like cussing or
anything like that you certainly didn't
see anything like you would see in the
2000s with like jessica jones and marvel
max but at the time in the 1970s it was
pretty intense right for like publishing
at that point in time it was a pretty
intense comic but this one in particular
set the groundwork for what would become
the sort of on-again off-again ally
slash friendship of blade and michael
morbius because while the vampire tales
stories dealt with uh michael morbius
really kind of getting his first quote
on quote solo run and dealing with a
woman named amanda saint basically
having to contend with a demon fire cult
they were quite literally called demon
fire that worshipped lucifer so those
are the kind of stories that you saw in
vampire tales his first encounter with
blade in this comic was blade trying to
kill him because he was a vampire it
wasn't until adventure into fear issue
number 24 in 1974 that you actually saw
blade and morbius working together when
blade realized that morbius was a living
vampire and had this kind of personal
plight that he had to contend with right
like he didn't want to kill people but
he basically had to feed on the blood of
others in order to keep himself alive
but tried to contend with that and tried
to make up for those actions by being a
superhero whenever he wasn't consuming
folks and just based on that of course
he and blade worked together to fight a
greater threat but that set the stage
for the relationship between the two
which would become wildly significant
not only in the 1990s but also going
into the late 1990s and so following
this the next major role for blade came
in marvel preview issue number three and
this was particularly important because
while tomb of dracula issue number 13
gave us kind of an origin but not really
all it told us is that blade basically
his mom had died because she was bitten
by a vampire when she was in the process
of giving birth to him and that he's
really just kind of been on the hunt for
his mother's killer ever since right
that's like his motivation for existing
and that's it that's all we got in terms
of an origin the funny thing about this
is that in issue number three of marvel
preview this is really one of those
instances when chris claremont was kind
of making a name for himself in marvel
comics as the guy who could not only
tell compelling stories something that
we would see really come to fruition in
his landmark run on the x-men but also
as the guy who could tell stories really
large form origins for individual
characters now for blade himself the
story was just kind of a continuation of
what we saw in terms of him hunting for
his mother's killer but as far as his
origin went it was actually the most
detailed we'd gotten up to that point
and what we found out is that basically
his mother was working in a brothel
right madam vanities were also kind of
uh giving or at least in the process of
giving birth there that the unnamed
person that had turned her was simply
described in the same way he hadn't been
named deacon frost yet he hadn't
actually been given that name per se in
marvel comics it was simply just a tall
guy with silver hair and glowing eyes
that had bit his mother and that
following that were that's where the
initial tomb of dracula story ended
chris claremont continued on by
basically saying that at nine years old
he had experienced kind of an attack
that actually turned out to be done by
vampires but he was rescued by a guy
named jamal afari who was himself a
vampire hunter and that jamal afari had
just kicked the drug habit or at least
was in the process of getting rid of it
took eric brooks under his wing as the
son he never had eric brooks saw him as
the father he never had and as what was
in effect father and son that jamal
taught eric brooks everything he needed
to know not only about how to play the
jazz trumpet but also everything he knew
about vampires now the caveat to this
and what was so wild about this is there
came a point when dracula tracked down
jamal and turned him to a vampire and
when that happened that's when eric
brooks had to kill his mentor and that's
why eric brooks held a very particular
hatred towards dracula himself as kind
of a secondary thing defining his
mother's killer and why he and dracula
had fought so much over the course of
the tomb of dracula's story but i wanted
to wait until this particular point in
his publication history to illustrate
that this sort of origin and this feud
between dracula and and in blade is
really the result of retcon in marvel
comics it didn't initially start out
that way it was just changed later on
but that's why marvel preview number
three is so significant for blade
because where he was a teenager just
hunting down vampires and using whatever
fighting tactics he had to overcome them
the reality is that he was unpolished he
was untrained jamal afari largely fixed
a lot of that taught him the things he
needed to know to be an effective
vampire hunter so in a lot of ways
dracula had essentially killed the
father of eric brooks even if he was not
his biological father and so where blade
was rolled back over into the tomb of
dracula stories in uh really in 1975
running all the way up until the series
cancellation that what you found was
that aside from blade helping dracula
defeat a villain named dr sun and then
asking dracula to help him track down
the vampire that killed his mother and
of course that being refused and the two
of them sort of fighting there wasn't a
whole lot doing with blade in relation
to dracula he had some significant
moments there but nothing overly
valuable and in fact following this in
1977 or following 1977 he actually
disappeared from marvel comics for about
six years returning in doctor strange
issue number 61 in 1974 with what was in
effect believed to have been the death
of dracula at the time and then
following that vanished entirely from
marvel comics until you got to 1990. now
the funny thing about blade's return
came with kind of tomb of dracula volume
2 when it was issues two through four
there wasn't a whole lot doing here
outside of the fact that everybody was
convinced he was crazy and he ended up
in a mental institution the reality here
is that dan chichester in 1992
had basically brought back blade in what
was in effect a wholesale rework of the
supernatural and mythological side of
marvel comics and that's one of the
things to know when it comes to
different sides of marvel really only
one part of marvel has remained intact
since its inception and that's the
traditional role of superheroes right
good guys fighting bad guys so like the
role of the fantastic four the role of
spider-man or the x-men or something
like that different threats have emerged
over the years regarding those
characters but by and large since their
introduction they haven't really changed
all that much and a lot of it was
because seminal stories involving those
characters took place in the early days
of their publication history which set
the stage for what they were about right
like the introduction of the sinister
six and spider-man annual number one
when it came to the supernatural side of
marvel it was just kind of like whatever
and so the way this played out is that
over the course of blades publication
history what you saw was a coming
together of blade alongside two other
guys frank drake and hannibal king and
the way these characters operated is
that in the early 1990s marvel
introduced a group called borderline
investigations so what these guys did is
they essentially investigated things
that dealt with like vampires and so on
and so forth it was a way to take the
characters of of blade and frank and
hannibal and give them more of a
purposeful role in marvel comics because
up to that point they were just kind of
running around in these individual books
hunting vampires things like that now
one of the cool things here is that this
was part of a larger story that would
introduce what we know as the midnight
suns and so that's why if you ever look
up marvel comics you'll see two groups
you'll see the midnight suns composed of
the night stalkers and then basically
everybody else but the whole idea behind
this was again a reworking of the
supernatural mythos of marvel and so
this era of blades history is as much a
kind of reworking of blade as it is the
supernatural stuff and so within this
era of storytelling this kind of night
stalkers comic book run that in night
stalkers number one which is when blade
really made his return after all these
years that he took on the appearance
that we most commonly see with this
character right the leather jacket or
the black leather jacket and all that
kind of stuff but the larger story here
dealt with the return or the emergence
of a woman by the name of lilith who was
literally like the mother of demons and
so this whole thing regarding like frank
and and hannibal and blade being brought
back together again uh the idea of like
morbius and ghost rider and so on and so
forth all those individuals coming
together was actually done at the
manipulation of doctor strange in order
to bring them together to have them
essentially overcome the forces of
lilith and so that's why you ended up
seeing things like the midnight massacre
stuff like that where blade got his
hands on the dark hole believing it
could be used to destroy the occult all
the while not realizing that the purpose
behind this is that that individual who
used the darkhold would basically become
the new demogorge so essentially a kind
of god among gods but would be under the
control of catholic the whole time so in
effect blade using the darkhold would
quite literally lead to catholic
returning to earth ultimately of course
he was stopped and the day was saved and
that kind of thing but that really that
kind of discussion goes largely into the
nature of the midnight suns more than it
simply does focusing on blade and so
while i am kind of skimming through his
time as part of the midnight suns and
the night stalkers just because of the
fact that again that's really more of a
discussion about the nature of the
midnight suns themselves one of the
things that i do want to point out here
is there were some very significant
moments that came out of this comic book
run specifically the night stalkers
themselves and the the larger role that
played with blade in the sense that
blade as we know him now really began to
take form during night stalkers now one
of the funny things about this is that a
lot of the nightstalkers origin is
really told in hindsight which is to say
that during this time when blade was
basically missing that it was dr strange
that it kind of manipulated things
behind the scenes that you had drake and
you had these guys who were operating as
borderline investigations but that kind
of took place off panel and that once
the team really came back around and
effectively reformed it was doctor
strange manipulating things to ensure
that group reformed and that they would
run into the other individuals that
would make up the larger midnight sun's
team in order to face off against lilith
but marvel of course did this because
blade was considered such an outlier in
marvel that rolling him in with doctor
strange or having doctor strange kind of
incorporate that group in there brought
them closer in line with quote-unquote
main marvel comics as a whole and really
made the team more i guess relatable or
acceptable by the general reader base
that wasn't really looking to read
anything that was considered french the
issue that you had with blade at this
point in time at least following the
whole night stalkers cancellation and
everything is that when it came to him
showing back up on the scene in marvel
comics in the early 1990s and you had
him forming the night stalkers along
with frank and hannibal and then you had
the the really them joining in with
everybody else and forming the loose
knit group the midnight suns is that
with this story arc it was done for a
particular purpose but once lilith and
her lilin were defeated there wasn't
really a way to tell a compelling story
with blade because you were kind of back
to square one with what do we do with
this guy who's hunting vampires and his
real major nemesis is deacon frost that
story was wrapped up in in the old tomb
of dracula stories the dracula himself
kind of comes around every once in a
while but at this point in time in the
1990s nobody really wanted to see comics
where blade was fighting dracula because
by this point so much work had been done
with so many other superheroes that that
was just exceedingly basic storytelling
that with chris claremont and the x-men
what you had was like a soap opera
featuring the x-men it was very
character-driven the fantastic four were
now a multiversal exploration team that
when it came to groups like the avengers
they had these massive space-faring
escapades in addition to all the stories
on earth then you got blade fighting
dracula it just didn't stick and so
while you did get stories like blade
vampire hunter issues 1 through 10 by
ian edgenton or you had stories like
blade crescent city blues at the end of
the day you also had the common bust of
the mid 1990s right we kind of talked
about that in the past about how fans
were buying comics thinking they would
just increase in value forever which led
to marvel and dc publishing more of
those comics which drove down the value
because now you had like 15 copies of
like an issue number one of a comic book
that the results of this is that people
just stopped buying comics so marvel
started going belly up and what this
meant is that marvel stopped publishing
stories or at least hiring the best
writers and best artists for stories if
they didn't think they were bankable and
so blade going from the mid to late
1990s was quite literally a reflection
of superheroes that were suffering under
the comic boss of the 1990s you can
track blade by that his stories weren't
compelling they weren't overly
interesting they were intriguing for
what they were but unless you were a big
time blade fan you couldn't really get
anything out of it the result of this is
that blade fell completely and almost
totally into obscurity with the
exception of only those fans who love
supernatural stuff but all that changed
when the blade film came out now the
interesting thing about this is that as
most of you guys know from the blade
film he's a day walker right he can walk
around in broad daylight basically even
though he's a vampire and kill vampires
while they're sleeping it's one of the
most menacing aspects of his character
as far as vampires go in the comics he
didn't become a day walker until around
this same time as well now that happened
in peter parker's spider-man issue 7-8
uh when he was bitten by michael morbius
and because of the nature of michael
morbius's vampirism right being a living
vampire that this spread to eric brooks
and it wasn't until you got to the newly
relaunched blade issue number one that
you actually saw him uh operating as a
day walker realizing the full extent of
what the bite of michael morbius did and
allowing him to walk around in the
daytime but there isn't really a clear
cut explanation here as to which one
came first is it one of those things
where because the blade film was going
to focus on him being a day walker that
the events of peter parker's spiderman
number seven and eight were basically
done in order to coincide with the film
or if the comics were already fleshed
out and the film copied the comics we
don't really know and we don't have a
full-fledged explanation there what we
do know however is whether it was
because of the film or the comic
following the film and the comic blade
went forward as a vampire that could
walk around in broad daylight and what
this did is it opened up a host of new
possibilities for what marvel could do
because the alternative was to have him
running around at night killing vampires
where he found him and like that was it
by allowing him to operate during the
day it meant he could function when
other superheroes were functioning and
because he could do that now there was
ample room for team ups and so what you
saw here following 1999 in in peter
parker's spider-man uh issues seven and
eight as well as the blade film was just
this explosion of appearances in blade
in all these different comic books where
it never happened before now the other
part of this is that because the movie
was so popular marvel just threw them
everywhere right they put them all over
the place and people ate it up because
the general person out there who had
never heard of blade had gone to see
this movie with wesley snipes being the
big name draw and was like who the hell
is blade ran to the local comic book
store and suddenly there was blade all
over the place and so while marvel did
relaunch blade vampire hunter as blade
vol 2 it was cancelled shortly after
because it was the same problem that it
always was with blade marvel didn't know
how to write a good story about him
really one of the things to know about
his character what makes blade
intriguing isn't so much himself it's
the circumstances that he's in and the
teams that he's a part of that makes him
interesting on his own he's just a guy
who hunts vampires and while for some
people that may be a really intriguing
element of his character for most people
it wasn't and so that's why when you got
blade vol 3 which was basically a marvel
max line that story was really really
cool but that story dealt with a group
called the trikes or tricks or whatever
you want to call them which were
essentially the marvel comics adaptation
of the reapers from blade 2. it was
interesting for what it was but unless
you saw blade 2 you didn't really care
and so it's one of those weird and wonky
situations for a character that doesn't
resonate but again he had some
interesting stories for example blade
vol 4 basically dealt with him being
sent back in time by doctor doom uh he
ultimately ended up coming or at least
saving the life of his father only to
find out that his father was aware of a
prophecy to essentially resurrect
dracula to return vampire souls to their
bodies making them invulnerable that
blade ended up having to kill his own
friend hannibal different things along
those lines but again you know it didn't
necessarily resonate too much however
it's not to say that there was never
anything beneficial about this guy again
we're kind of running short on time here
so sort of fast tracking a little bit
kind of giving you guys the highlights
one of the more interesting moments that
came with blade and really recent memory
actually came out of mighty avengers now
this is mighty avengers vol 2 the first
mighty avengers actually was led by
carol danvers was part of the original
civil war event really the aftermath of
civil war where she was kind of like the
long arm of the law so to speak where
she essentially operated to apprehend
any superheroes out there who refused to
register after civil war was over and
the bad guys essentially won right like
registration was the law of the land
with mighty avengers vol 2 this actually
came really sprung bored off of jonathan
hickman's infinity and like thanos and
the coal obsidian showing up and like
ebony maw tricking doctor strange or
kind of forcing doctor strange to summon
schumacher to this plane of existence
and so on and so forth blade showed up
here and he was actually donning the
moniker of ronin and depending on who
you are as a blade fan people love that
and indeed that's probably one of the
cooler moments of his character when he
was operating as a version of ronan in
marvel comics it was pretty solid but
for the most part right now in marvel
comics and as it really has been for a
number of years blate's just kind of
there he's just a guy who's there and
marvel tells stories about him sometimes
and sometimes are interesting sometimes
they're not at the moment right now he
is on jason aaron's avengers team how
long that's gonna last i don't entirely
know you can bet your bottom dollar when
the the movie comes out he's gonna get
his own comic if he hasn't already he's
gonna get his own comic book out there
and i'm sure people are probably gonna
read it for a little while but the real
test here the real question is can a
compelling story be written about blade
because he is at the end of the day a
phenomenal superhero he has a really
really intriguing backstory but he never
really has any stories that you're
actually interested in reading so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end i'm sorry all the blade
fans out there
you know i don't mean to smash on the
guy it's just i think it's important to
make sure that people look at blade in
perspective but we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace